ce parti mais aujourd'hui on va pas là
d'un sujet qui me tient à coeur et en
fait je vais vous raconter une histoire
avant de commencer une histoire met
évidemment en rapport avec la vidéo avec
ce qu'on va faire juste après vous
l'avoir racontez vous en faites pas
c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
s'appelait hochart lucas est cette
enfant dé beaucoup de mal à différencier
le bleu du rose du gris ouais c'est la
fin de l'histoire c'est très courant
alors les amis je pense être daltonien
mais vous savez il ya plusieurs degrés
de daltonisme ça concerne différentes
couleurs etc bref
et moi j'ai du mal avec les couleurs
comme le bleu le rose le gris voilà
c'est vrai je sors ces exemples-là
puisque c'est le truc est plus flagrant
et je me suis embrouillé plusieurs fois
que des gens de ma famille parce que je
disais non ce truc heroes est
merveilleuse et banon manon lucas
vraiment ces bleus un aïeul s'érode et
c'était avant que je découvre ce qui
était le daltonisme tout simplement
le daltonisme c'est génétique ok ça veut
dire qu'il ya forcément quelqu'un ta
famille qui te l'a transmis à faire
quelqu'un m'a envoyé par mail ce site
nkrumah qui permet de faire un test de
ta vision des couleurs je crois que ça
qu'on s'y juste avoir des chiffres dans
des trucs de couleur bois par exemple
j'en vois pas c'est normal je pense là
il ya 1,5 par contre start est
instruction tu vas voir une image
composée de petits pointus pour avoir
l'image que pendant quelques secondes
tu dois trouver le nombre qui est caché
dans les amas de points ce sera un
chiffre compris entre 1 et 9
ok cliquer sur le bouton approprié pour
indiquer ce que tu as vu au kénya pas
plus simple c'est nickel ok ce parti
alors là c'est 1 1 on le voit très
clairement à web et à la barre contre tu
vois pas le 1 c'est je pense que c'est
que tu es un daltonien vénère je connais
pas le nom des différents types de
daltonisme et se différencient juste par
le fait que y'en a qui vaut un bal vert
et ne voit pas le rouge avec enfin voilà
sept députés c'est ce qu'on a la
perception de certaines couleurs est
altérée voilà mais c'est pas toujours
les mêmes enfin bref bon c'est
clairement un pas se mentir c'est un oh
oui à l'autre bonjour alors l'armée mais
ils m'appellent trois fois par jour
depuis dix jours j'en ai marre en plus
je suis même plus chez vous laissez moi
en paix [ __ ] arrêté de force elle a
alors plus important ce qu'on est en
train de faire c'est ainsi c'est
évidemment à la sachant une couleur
maintenance et du rouge sur du verre
pita j'aimerais bien qu'ils expliquent à
chaque fois ci si tu vois pas le chiffre
là par exemple quel type de daltonisme
tu as là ça va c'est un 8
j'ai dû beaucoup de mal là mais bon je
pense que vous aussi mais bon au final
c'est un 8 ça se voit maintenant il ya
un bouton rien auquel aérien ok [ __ ]
ils m'ont fait peur à 9,1 cette tasse
est flagrant lancée du bleu sur du verre
je le vois super bien c'est bizarre
parce que pourtant c'est du cours de
lingerie qui me pose un peu problème la
c1 je vais super biton à tanger l'argent
qui est un chiffre à voir les charges en
plus je m'éloigne mieux je vais le voir
ici à des trucs un peu rose aimée jeu sa
forme pas un chiffre wallace a commencé
avec le choix qui est un saint clar
savez comment c'est super difficile
[ __ ] c'est terrible moyen 5 icloud il
ya 1,2 c16 c'est quoi on dirait un ace -
0 ses insistent les amis bien sûr c'est
évident c'est 1,6 et 1,7 non mais
attends quand c'est flagrant comme ça
c'est impressionnant
n'empêche john dalton là le mec qui a
découvert le daltonisme puisqu'il était
lui-même daltoniens c'est pas le mec qui
a dû le plus embrouillée un gars au
monde la robe bleue la robe rose ça a
duré deux heures contre lui la robe il a
maintenu qu'elle était rose mais pendant
dix jours alors là y'a rien mais ça
c'est tellement flagrant que ça pour moi
l'as tu vois pas 3 c'est que tu as le
type de daltonisme à ces veinards je
pense là y'a 1 6 6 1 3 et 1 3 pts 1
c'est ça que je vois mal c'est ça là je
vois plus le 3 c'est ça que je vois
grave ma la [ __ ] donc c'est bien vert
bleu quoi un verbe 3 1
ouais 5 ça aussi j'ai un peu de mal mais
ça va
lassé de 7,4 bien évidemment tu as he
les ailes et je suis top était palpitant
pour vous mais je tout excité de voir
du coup ce que ce que je vais avoir en
fait qu'un petit de daltonisme à merde
[ __ ] c'est quoi ça emmerde et dans
l'imitation du mec qui est sûr c'est le
net n'est ce pas non c'est un cas très
aérien baiia 1 2 non par contre là ça
commence à être super dur avoir vraiment
ça m'étonnerait pas qu'il est plein de
gens d'entre vous qui arrive pas non
plus avoir le lécher les chiffres mais
qu'ils soient pas pour autant daltonien
oh là là mais mexes et d'une difficulté
d'avoir ça c'est incroyable mais que
j'aime concentré sa mère c'est terrible
à la c'est tellement dans black black
black c'est un bien sûr c'est vrai
séverin de fuck atteint même plus je
suis content de me lever parce que quand
tu gagnes quand une baisse les couleurs
de l'écran elles sont pas pareils lancé
vrai quand tu es en bas c'est plus
sombre quand et où tu sais plus lumineux
que la part des choses je vois pas
l'expliquer mais chose à un choc c'est
fini je suis mme hilde de thann
alors les deux tonnes sont les gens avec
l'a2 terre anomalie c'est une mauvaise
perception des couleurs rouge et vert
mais attend un changement je n'arrive
pas y croire c'est sûr et certain tous
les gens qui ont regardé la vidéo
ils ont eu du mal au truc où c'était
rouge sur l'air aussi non agissait pas à
100 je dis ça mais en fait pas du tout
donc mais quand et qui sont censés
détecter le vert le détecte pas assez et
par contre ils sont trop sensibles au
jaune à l'orangé au rouge du coup le
vert le jaune l'orangé le rouge et le
marron vous paraissent similaires
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
surtout en basse lumière encore moins il
peut aussi être difficile de trouver la
différence entre le bleu et le violet ou
le rose ou le gris à ben alaoui ben
alaoui mec c'est drôle là ça correspond
à près ce que c'est le hasard ou pas
mais qu assez dur là parce que la
première partie du résumé nous
correspond enfin ou alors j'ai pas
spécialement remarqué ma difficulté à
différencier le jaune le vert l'orangé
le rouge mais par contre qu'ils ont dit
après le bleu et le violet et le rose et
le gris mec c'est ça c'est le rose et le
gris a put un habitat qui savait quoi on
va plus ma grand-mère et on va lui
demander quelles couleurs mon grand-père
avait du mal à voir comment tu vas bah
ça va très bien en fait j'ai fait une
vidéo où je faisais à un test de dalton
isme et ils me disent qu en gros j'ai du
mal à différencier le bleu et le violet
et le gris et le
rose est ce que tu te souviens papilles
quel coup là il avait du mal à voir bah
c'est marrant parce que c'est exactement
comme moi vous avez des embrouilles
plusieurs fois il était têtu bah voilà
bah celui cool que tu t'en souviens
assez rigolo bois là et ben écoute c'est
un mystère de d'élucider grâce à toi
donc je te remercie et puis je te dis à
très vite mon ami je te fais pas un gros
bisou à ma vie bateau aussi bisous mon
ami à bientôt je t'aime lisa elle n'est
pas incroyable morissette à vous et à
vos doigts tout envie de le câliner et
ben les amis six apprentis visa n'était
pas allé mais si elle vous a plu et ben
écoutez j'ai je suis très content parce
que j'ai trouvé ce que j'ai donc en fait
c'est juste une mauvaise perception de
la couleur verte je vais me faire un
café et je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]